Apple has completely changed their
entire iPad lineup with the launch of
the brand new iPad 10 generation and the
2022 iPad Pro M2 and a lot of people in
the tech space are agreeing that this is
the most confusing iPad lineup ever from
Apple and I've gotta agree with that and
now it's really hard to choose because
you have six different iPads right here
look the iPad Mini the iPad 9 which is
the previous generation still for sale
the new iPad 10 with the redesign the
iPad Air with the M1 then the 11 and
12.9 inch M2 iPad Pros but what makes
things even more confusing is that these
brand new iPads that Apple just released
have some problems which I'm gonna
explain in this video which is leading
people to be buying some of the previous
generations that are no longer for sale
but actually still a great deal now as
you probably already know the new iPad
10 5 finally gets the redesign that all
the other iPads have enjoyed for a while
now with the flat sides the flat back
and the all screen design with the
removal of the home button finally on
top of that it joins the rest of the new
iPads with a USBC port on the bottom
which is amazing and by far the weirdest
thing about it is that it still supports
the first generation apple pencil even
though it has the new flat redesign
which should have had the magnetic
wireless charging system for the second
generation apple pencil and making it
even worse which is just absolutely
stupid and ridiculous since the first
gen apple pencil has the lightning port
for charging you can't plug it into the
iPad itself which is what you used to do
which is already ridiculous but now it's
worse because you have to use a USBC to
lightning adapter to charge it and to
pair it yes it's required to pair it and
some people are saying that it's not
even included in the Box you have to buy
it separately from Apple and another
really cool thing about the new iPad 10
is that it also has a new magic keyboard
folio that is specifically designed for
this model and what makes it really
unique is that compared to the magic
keyboard case for the iPad Pro or the
iPad Air like I have right here you can
actually detach the keyboard section on
the bottom while keeping the back of it
intact and use it as a stand just like
you can see on Apple's website this is
awesome especially since it has the
function function keys which the
original magic keyboard for the more
expensive iPad Pro does not have and
speaking of the M2 iPad Pro this is
basically the most disappointing update
ever because there's only a couple of
changes you get the M2 Chip instead of
the M1 you get Bluetooth 5.3 which is
nice and Wi-Fi 6E which is also nice but
other than that there's really no other
major changes yes you can record with
prores but who's going to be recording
with an iPad and finally the new M2 iPad
Pro supports the new hover apple pencil
which seems more like a software feature
to me because it's been available on
Samsung tablets since 2012. but anyway
those were the new iPads and now let's
get into the actual prices of the entire
six iPad lineup first of all you have
the previous generation iPad 9 which you
can now get on sale for 300 which is
honestly a really good deal because the
new iPad had 10 starts at 450 dollars
with the same 64 gigs of storage then of
course we have the iPad Mini 6 which is
on sale for 459 dollars basically 10
bucks more than the iPad 10 and the
benefit with this guy compared to that
is that you get a laminated display with
P3 colors which is really nice you have
the support for the apple pencil second
generation with no weirdness with that
whole adapter that you need and you have
the a15 bionic chip as well as the very
nice portable design but of course this
cannot support a full keyboard like the
new magic keyboard folio which gives
some points to the iPad 10. and now of
course you also have the iPad Air 5
which is usually 600 but it's now on
sale for 519 which is actually a pretty
good deal and by the way all these
Amazon deals I'll give links to down in
the description below so definitely
check those out now however I would not
recommend this new iPad Air 5 because
there are only a couple of differences
that might not be that big of a deal to
you guys as you can see right here I
have the iPad Air in the middle and the
iPad 10 on the right they both have 10.9
inch displays the air has the M1 chip
which is a lot more performance while
the iPad has the A14 which by the way
I'm gonna get into because it's not the
full story of course they both have the
12 megapixel cameras on the front with
the iPad 10 finally having a landscape
camera which is actually a big win they
both have USBC support for 5G and the
iPad Air has the benefit of having the
P3 wide color gamut with the
anti-reflective coating and fully
laminated display but honestly other
than that there's not that many
advantages with the iPad Air yes you do
have apple pencil 2nd gen support but
not much else and even the bluetooth
specs are better on the new iPad 10 you
have Bluetooth tooth 5.2 so with that
said I'd honestly recommend going with
the iPad 10 over the new iPad Air 5.
however things change when you look at
the iPad Air 4 that was back in 2020 and
it is very similar to the new iPad Air 5
with only a few changes of course it has
the same A14 chip as the new iPad 10
however it's actually going to be faster
in terms of graphics performance because
Apple mentioned in their Newsroom
article that the A14 chip and the iPad
10 is only 10 faster than the previous
iPad 9 in terms of GPU performance which
actually means it's going to be very
slow around 7 700 GPU score in metal
geekbench 5 compared to over 12
000 with the iPad Airs version of the
A14 so you're going to get better
performance with this guy right here
which by the way a renewed on Amazon
only 430 bucks even cheaper than the new
iPad 10. this is the one I would go with
if you're considering the iPad 10 to be
completely honest and then finally we
have the new M2 iPad Pros both in the 11
inch and 12.9 inch sizes now the M2 is
actually a decent deal eight hundred
dollars and you're getting the promotion
120 hertz display you're getting the
extra camera system on the back with
lidar you're getting Thunderbolt
connectivity you're getting Bluetooth
5.3 and Wi-Fi 6E there are some good
advantages with the main one being the
pro motion display that's the main
reason I would go with the new iPad Pro
however you can still find a renewed M1
iPad Pro the previous model for 650
dollars renewed on Amazon that is
actually a killer deal only 200 bucks
more than the new iPad 10. this might be
the one what people want to go with if
they want a really nice high-end iPad
best bang for the buck without spending
way too much money this is a really
really good deal but now with all that
said let me give you guys a quick
buyer's guide rundown of all of these
iPads and which ones I recommend for
each use case if you're just looking for
the cheapest new and fresh iPad you can
get I would honestly recommend still the
iPad and 9th gen for only 300 bucks on
Amazon that's still a very good deal now
if you want something for your kids
that's still portable fresh powerful
really this iPad Mini 6 is great it's
perfect for gaming for kids everything
the modern design USBC it's got
everything built in I really like this
for only around 450 bucks the same price
as the iPad 10. so if you can spend at
least 450 I'd probably go with this one
now if you want a larger display like a
10.9 inch and you want to use that new
magic keyboard folio to kind of use it
as a laptop replacement then honestly
the iPad 10 is still a great deal but on
the other hand you can just get the
renewed iPad Air 4. at this point I do
not recommend the iPad Air M1 the fifth
generation I don't think it's a good
price even on sale don't get it either
get one of the other ones or go up to
the iPad Pro and with that said speaking
of the iPad Pro I probably would not get
the M2 version unless you really care
about the extra performance maybe you
really love that hover apple pencil
feature that you really want or you care
a lot about Wi-Fi 6E and Bluetooth 5.3
then maybe you should get the new M2
iPad Pro but while you can you could
just get the M1 models so with that said
hopefully this video got rid of some of
that confusion and helps you decide
which iPad you should buy definitely
check out the links to all those great
sales down below and let me know what
you think in the comment section click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and we'll see you
in the next video
[Music]